so let's see if we can subtract 25 from
83 or if we can figure out what 83 minus
25 is and I encourage you to pause the
video and see if you can work through it
so I'm assuming you've had a try and
when you try to work through it you
probably first went to the ones place
right over here and you probably said
hey I have three ones on top and from
that I want to subtract five ones but
then you said wait I can't subtract five
ones from three ones five is more than
three what do I do and what you do is
what I'm about to show you you do
something called regrouping you take
some of the value that's in the tens
place and put it into the ones place
what am I talking about now I'm going to
do it three different ways so you really
hopefully understand what's going on
well you want this three to be more ones
you want it to be it you want it to be
at least as large as five or larger so
how do you do that well you could take a
10 from the tens place so instead of
having eight tens here you could take
one of them away and then you're going
to have seven tens here and then if you
take a ten because I just took a ten
away from here you put in the ones place
that's going to be 10 so 10 plus 3 is 13
10 plus 3 is 13 so what did i do again
83 is eight tens and three ones you
could also think of it as seven tens and
13 ones and I'm going to do it again in
a couple of different ways to make that
clear but let's just work through this
now because now you have 13 ones minus
five ones which is going to be eight
ones and then you go to the tens place
and you say seven tens minus two tens
well that's going to be five tens so
your answer is going to be five tens and
eight ones or 58 now I said I would do
this several ways so that it makes a
little bit more sense so let's do that
so another way that you could write 83
is you could write this this is the same
thing as 80 80 plus three eighty plus
three that's the same thing as 83 eight
tens three ones eight tens three ones
and 25 is the
same thing is the same thing as 20 plus
5 20 plus 5 now we're going to subtract
20 plus 5 so let's write this instead as
we're going to subtract 20 we're going
to subtract 2 tens and we're going to
subtract 5 ones so subtracting 25 is the
same thing as subtracting 20 and then
subtracting 5 so now let's try to work
through it just like we did well we go
to the ones place again and once again
with a 5 if I want to take 5 away from 3
that's hard I don't know how to do that
just yet but what if I take 10 from here
so if I take a 10 if I take 10 from
there that's going to be 70 and if I put
that 10 in the ones place well 10 plus 3
is going to be 13 notice I haven't
changed the value of the number 70 plus
13 is the exact same thing as 80 plus 3
which is 83
but what's useful about this is now in
the ones place I can subtract 5 from 13
well if I subtract 5 from 13 I'm going
to get an 8 and then if I subtract 2
tens from 7 tens or 20 from 70 I'm going
to get 50 I'm going to get 50 so this is
going to end up being 50 plus 8 which is
the exact same thing as 58 five tens and
eight ones now I said I would do it a
third way and these are all the same way
I'm just writing it down in different
ways so I could also write 83 I could
write this down as 8 tens eight tens
plus three ones plus three ones all
right this is the tens place this is the
ones place eight tens three ones now I'm
going to subtract two tens and five ones
so I could write so this is going to be
minus minus two tens minus two tens and
minus three ones I'm sorry and minus
five ones minus five ones 25 is the same
thing as two as as 20 and five if I'm
subtracting 25 that's
same thing as subtracting 20 and then
subtracting five and that's the same
thing as subtracting two tens and then
subtracting five ones two tens and five
ones so let's then work this out so this
is going to be well as soon as we try to
subtract five ones from three ones we
say anyway that's not making any sense
let me make the value here larger and
I'm going to do that by regrouping from
the tens place so instead of writing
this as eight tens I'm going to take one
of those tens away I'm going to write it
as seven tens and then put that 10 in
the ones place well ten 110 is equal to
ten ones so if I add it to the three
this is going to be 13 ones and now I
can subtract 13 ones minus five ones is
eight ones and seven 10s minus two tens
is five times five tens and we are done
these are all different ways of doing
this exact same problem with regrouping